[Music]
please answer your pimp apparatus
please answer your pimp apparatus
all right late late the great yes sir
welcome back i'm happy to be here it's
been about a year i'm happy to be back
though it's been a while right mm-hmm
what tell us what's what's going on with
you since the last time we we talked oh
man
mo over what else you know i mean just
the basic the basic [ __ ] that you know
i'm saying i go through you know getting
money
you know ducking and dodging staying on
top you know the basics
so uh you have some new girls since last
time you were here right
well hey man i got to answer that
question similar to how i answered one
would you ask me
am i still active man i can't confirm or
deny all i got to say is
you know i still do my thing what it
takes for me to survive i understood
i understood so you've been doing this
for how long hey man you know i've been
familiar with the pepe culture since the
90s
since 1999. and you operate in what
neighborhoods huh
because you actually without making that
admission that i'm active okay
my familiarity of it you know i ain't
mad and got down on fig
sunset uh all throughout new york and
hunts point midtown manhattan all up and
down eighth avenue
should uh support it in the valley
languish him [ __ ] even downtown straight
up some skid row money you know what i'm
saying but i made it feel like beverly
hills money though you know what i'm
saying with the caliber of women i had
out there so i mean you know i haven't
been around man i didn't make my rounds
i'd have my fair share of you know
what it takes to make a person a worthy
participant in this game
and the the girls that you'll
help um
some of your girls i've met and they've
drugs have been a part of their lives
right
oh man you know hey man they say some
say you get it all for the wound and not
for the spoon man but you know uh
it's not necessarily a guarantee that a
pimp is going to put put his business
out there what drug or girl does you
know what i'm saying cause i don't make
you like you know the sack is a pen but
not him but you know
i'm gonna tell you like this though just
to advocate for everybody who's had a
drug added girl out there has a drug
addict girl right there
if a girl go out there and work a shift
and make
seven hundred dollars and she comes back
to the house faithfully in pocket like a
good host post do with a pimp and she
only consumes 80 yards of dope you just
made more off of that sack than the dope
dealer did
so hey man you know it ain't really
nothing to knock it's not what's done is
how it's getting done with the progress
consists of while it's happening
what about drugs for you oh man i'm drug
free man you know i don't get high off
with nothing but life and making money
in progress
not even pot not even pot man this this
thing right here in my hands the only
thing that i consume period you know i
don't need i don't need to uh
you know be devoted to a substance or
some endorphins being released in my
brain
from a controlled substance that's going
to make me feel better than you know
what i'm saying the feeling of
progress and getting money and you're
going
as far as the pimp goes your style is
what because there's many different
styles of attempting
i can't i can't have one designated
style because as we're dealing with
individuals everybody
operates in an individual capacity so i
have to have that versatility man i
might have a girl over who's a
knucklehead so i got to respond to her
in a way that guys respond to girls who
are knuckles i might have a girl over
here that's a sweetheart
i got to respond and operate with her as
a sweetheart you know it it's versatile
man you got to know how to how to shift
it up it's just like when you're driving
down a dirt road you're driving down a
dirt road
it's best to have a full wheeled car
drive that's built for it tough or you
know you get what i'm saying
if if you up if you're up in the sky you
have to know how to take the pilot wheel
you know what i'm saying the cockpit of
the airplane you get what i'm saying so
you have to know how to switch it up man
there's not no one designated style
it's just like the nba right the nba has
one general set of rules
okay that everybody has will bye bye in
order to stay in the game and not get a
technicality or a foul or anything like
that called on them right
however each player on the court still
plays and operates the same way michael
jordan
was different than magic johnson but
there was still a certain
certain rules within the boundaries of
the nba that they didn't step outside of
yet they had their own
own individual style and they made
progress doing it their way
while staying within those rules and
guidelines in the nba same thing with
the dmv
they give every driver when they when
they read the manual when they take the
driver's test there's one set of rules
man you know don't run a red light
you know stop at a stop sign even if
nobody's around you know so forth and so
on right
but no two people drive a like but
what's important with that is if they
get from point a to point b
safely so same thing man
what are your thoughts on prostitution
being the oldest profession
since a woman is young she becomes aware
of value as far as you know
the company of a womanhood right so
you know they capitalize on that when
they grow up so it comes to more like
when they're in adults they realize okay
men are success symbols somebody that
can take care of me or somebody that
could be
somewhat of a benefactor to my
well-being okay
and then while they're sex symbols okay
like if i look good i'm gonna be
qualified
for somebody that's got it to want to
take care of me so it's kind of a thing
that goes hand-in-hand and that concept
is kind of common sense in human nature
man since the beginning of time
so you know that's why that phrase is in
is in you know existence right now
what's more important do you love her
money hey man uh
i answered that question before but let
me see let me see why i stand with it
right now
man as you know i said last time man you
know i'd rather have i'd rather have a
uh
uh respect and money because that's the
coupons coupons of life and so forth
but um you know love here's the thing
love coming from a woman like i told you
before it's usually a term of endearment
the girls are emotional creatures
whether they're a working girl or not
right
so they quickly carpet emotions say i
love you and this and that while a girl
is acknowledging the man along those
lines
that's cool because i mean [ __ ] you know
if she's telling you i don't like you
i'm feeling some type of way about your
presence whatever y'all trying to have
going on you know it's the woman's
choice at the end of the day
okay so whatever y'all have going on you
know it's not gonna look like it's it's
smelling like roses so what a woman is
saying
shoot in terms of endearment toward you
i love you and stuff like that that's a
good sign
as far as the men saying it women
especially the qualified ones who looked
good enough to attract men
and been knowing that they had that
advantage for years since a little girl
if a guy's telling them oh baby i love
you they you know prostitutes here from
their tricks and they clients a whole
lot man i love you
you're so beautiful they start to take
an insult to that [ __ ] because it looks
like okay they look at like
here's a man telling me he loves me but
is he qualified for me to give a [ __ ]
about him
telling me that he loves me who the [ __ ]
is he if he's saying that to me a total
stranger or a girl he's picking up on
the streets he'll say to anybody he's
just before companionship
so it becomes nothing it becomes uh
superficial to him you feel me
yeah it's an interesting angle on it but
me myself
hey man i like whatever whatever's uh
progress is the result of at the end of
the day
if a person feels like they love me and
their performance and whatever it is
whatever the contract is whatever the
contract consists of
is reflecting their definition of love
then hey i'm gonna give it right back
cause me i don't go around telling
people i love you and this and i just
perform it
you feel me i don't have to tell a
person i love you not one time
to where my actions my behavior toward
them is a1
so you know that's my take on it right
there it doesn't mean i'm
i'm a cold-hearted person and oh i'm too
tough to say i love you to somebody
i just perform it man that's all i know
how to do i perform it when you know
it's
appropriate to do so what uh what
qualities do you look for in a girl
hey man i look for good looks i look
like i told you before the magic word
competency you know don't might want no
crazy [ __ ] no stupid [ __ ]
you know i mean she got to be somebody
that uh is eating communicate with good
communication you feel me communication
rules the nation man
because it brings dedication and um you
know if i can't communicate with a
person just like a regular relationship
if two people can't communicate man you
know you communicate to build bonds
and to to keep them solidified and also
to patch up things if there's no decent
line of communication there
then it's pointless it ain't gonna work
so communication
good looks because i mean [ __ ] nobody
wants an ugly [ __ ] so if you qualify
the way you can have you a cute [ __ ] on
your team somehow some way
whatever whatever it is your
relationship consists of that's a bonus
i mean we're men you're a man mark i'm a
man
one of the qualifications is always
beauty like i said women are sex symbols
and many success symbols
what about the ethics of uh tell me
about the ethics of sending a woman out
to go do this with with guys that are
questionable and maybe
are gonna do you know things that well i
look at it like this if a woman doesn't
have a pimp
while you sit back and just collect the
money i i look at it like this man if a
woman is going to have a pimp right
then the concept of her going out there
without a pimp
is not really making no difference
toward personal ethics and
morals and guidelines and what's right
what's wrong according to you know i'm
saying everybody's opinion differs on
what's right and wrong and stuff like
that so i mean
when it comes to work ethics when
there's a contract between a pimp and a
hoe
then you know that's part of the
performance part of behavior i was
telling you about that solidifies where
she stands on her because at the end of
the day it's the woman's choice so
if the woman is loyal to the person
whose management she's up under
then this shit's gonna work out because
there's a particular set of guidelines
set in place for certain reasons just
like the nba just like the dmv you know
what i'm saying those rules are in place
so
they you know they're they're less at
risk of hazardous [ __ ] from uh
unpredictable tricks
less at risk from going to jail less
less at risk from
getting distracted on some drug [ __ ] on
some uh some whatever consists of some
out-of-pocket [ __ ] right so if they're
dedicated to the set of rules
coming from the program that they're
involved with
just like a regular job this shit's
gonna work so ethics ethics is more
important than anything man i mean
because without that it's just like a
person that has to get up and go to a
nine to five every day so what you offer
is kind of guidance to keep them in line
keep them doing it
in regards to my familiarity of the game
man you know uh
uh the guidance is to let them know
how it's supposed to be done the
motivation is to let them know
that you know you got somebody here with
you that's going to give you that extra
push
you know what i'm saying that you don't
have when you're by yourself because
it's
for example mark you know most of us men
man we get up in the mirror and dress
every day we shave we iron our pants and
you know what i'm saying
we brush our teeth and stuff like that
somewhere in the back of our head a
certain percentage of our brain
is looking like i want to look good in
case there's a woman who likes what she
sees
you get what i'm saying so i mean you
know women can let that go
they're self-esteem they're they're
where they're at in life whatever phase
they're at in life
that can be put all the way to the side
they don't give a [ __ ] that's why you
see a cute [ __ ]
that's a bum you get what i'm saying
homeless don't care
people say oh you're so pretty they
don't even give a [ __ ] about that it's
neptune because they know how pretty
they are up under that bum outfit they
got on because that's a phase they're
going through a life
what the pimp does you know what i'm
saying is motivates them
to recognize and appreciate
that they're beyond that you get what
i'm saying and make money have a program
a lot of people can't do nothing without
motivation or push man a lot of people
a lot of people like if they got
somebody to please if they got
somebody to report to if they got
somebody to impress like i was just
saying about how
us men get up and we shave we want a
nice car we want wins we want
acknowledgement man we want a [ __ ] to
say wow that guy right there got it
going on so you're saying the pimp
uh gives them motivation to realize
their potential like i said before in my
last interview with you a year ago man
motivation and inspiration that's real
they're just something that sounds good
at rhymes you know i can spit rolls
rhymes all day
but it's the meaning behind it man so
motivation inspiration
is what's necessary because you want a
woman to feel good about herself you
want a woman to say okay if you motivate
me to look good stay good
stay clear minded follow a set of rules
what the [ __ ] am i getting out of this
you understand i'm saying so that goes
back to the theory of how
you know saying a girl has to see her
money not just
work and then live day by day paying for
hotel rooms paying for cigarettes
paying for gas like with the hamster on
the wheel effect putting all this work
and all this mileage and stuck in the
same spot she has to actually
see the progress so she could sit back
and say wow you know what
when he met me at day one this was the
situation a year later
this is a situation they like that [ __ ]
that's what it's all about i've heard
that a lot from a lot of guys yeah it's
the truth man
just a different version of it yeah
would you ever switch places with a girl
where you're you're out there on the
street making money
and she's collecting the money that you
bring in well you know what man during
my drug dealing days man you know i i
was out there
beating my feet to concrete you know
what i'm saying and uh on the front line
hustling
as far as on some can i put myself in a
woman's frame of mind that question is
uh the meaning the meaning applied to
that question if that's what it is
would be more like asking a wife and a
husband would you trade places for her
and get some dick pumped in your ass i
mean i was born a man man i can't think
like a woman don't try to you know i
mean
you know so i don't put myself in that i
don't even i don't even put myself in
that frame of mind but as far as being
the one to hustle
and having a girlfriend to bring it back
to you and stuff like that hey man you
know i've been in a situation
i'm sure all of us had you get what i'm
saying but when it's a pimping whole
relationship a pimp and hold contract
believe it or not even though the women
are doing the dirty part of the labor
there's a lot of behind-the-scenes work
man that the pimp is doing to keep that
operation going successfully
so it's an equal amount of work on both
fans just different types like you got
dr dre
and you got snoop dogg right just
because snoop dogg's on the mic
and and on front and center on the stage
doesn't mean that dr dre
is is is doing less work you get what
i'm saying he's behind the scenes making
beats
producing you know so forth and so on
he's doing his producer working snoop
dogg
is doing his performance work but it's
still an equal amount of work being put
into the project
so uh you you meet a girl who's like on
skid row here there's there's a lot of
homeless
girls okay do you ever see a girl like
that and and see that you could
you know as a lot of tim say elevate her
into uh
a moneymaker here's the thing with girls
on you know in in uh
homeless poverty-stricken environments
right if they look too cute they got too
much of a cuteness to him regardless of
their their current condition
they usually got a boyfriend why i've
seen i've seen boyfriend girlfriend
couples intense and [ __ ] like that man
and uh
you know them girls some of them girls
they come a lot of a man like for
example white couples they come from out
of state together they took a trip to
california
because you know it's a big old
attraction people out of state his life
is easier in los angeles
and they they come there and you know
the girl don't give a [ __ ] what you come
with
you can come with a big old dope sagger
for a drug of choice you come with a big
old bankroll car yeah baby it's my car
right here [ __ ] with me you know what
i'm saying do yourself a favor and
change your flavor
you can hear with all that right but if
she don't want to go she's not going to
budge your dope sack don't impress her
because she know how to get out turn a
date or two if her boyfriend allows it
she knows how to go out here to store do
some boots and steal it and take it
somewhere in the part of town where she
could cash it out buy her bag of dope
so it's not imminent that she needs the
assistance of a pimp so she got that
little bit to survive on where she gonna
hold on
to her boyfriend her comfort zone she's
always gonna always be able to fall back
on
knowing that he accepts accepts her in
every situation she go out [ __ ] a couple
dope dealers
come back home to him a couple weeks
later go out work for her work for a sac
mac pimp
you know what i'm saying go back to him
he accepts her you know guys like that
man it's not just that
they're in a relationship this is more
like a family member too now not just
her lover this is more like a brother to
it not just for lovers so them kind of
couples right there it's kind of hard to
break apart man so usually when the
girls end up choosing a different
situation
the guy goes to jail for boosting or for
warrants you know i'm saying [ __ ] like
that when it becomes imminent which i
said it wasn't
you know in the beginning of you know
what i'm saying answering the question
so i mean you know then some girls you
know
they feel like a [ __ ] they know
what he doing finally came along the
same you know a pimp would preferably
not go through the hassle of pulling a
bun [ __ ] up out of a tent or something
like that man cause for a lot of people
to even get themselves that deep in the
situation
it's looked at like you know that's a
[ __ ] that's a [ __ ] [ __ ] right there what
i'm
gonna try to turn the [ __ ] straight for
and i don't mean [ __ ] i don't mean [ __ ]
like a man born with testicles i mean
like
you know i mean not homosexuals but the
ones born without testicles
when i say [ __ ] i mean a disobedient
dope fiend conniving low down [ __ ] man
you know what i mean
that that phrase [ __ ] and the pym culture
you know has a broad meeting man for the
most part
it's a disobedient [ __ ] man i like to
show opposition to what's going on you
can give her a million dollars
uh the uh two answers of the drug of her
choice a hug and crying arms say baby
just please good
please be good and do right by me for
just one week and she won't do it it's
just in her nature man so you know i
mean
and a whole lot of other elements that
you know i'm saying makes her a [ __ ]
so you know that's what i mean when i
say [ __ ] [ __ ] are some of these girls
just
too out of control too too much of a
hustler to to
reign in and can keep in your stable
it's not even being so much of a hustler
man i mean you know
uh you mean a [ __ ] [ __ ] uh any girls
i mean oh
i mean you know uh uh when when a pimp
propositioned a prostitute to work for
him man and you know what i'm saying
tries to recruit her interviewing stuff
like that
you know the likeliness of her choosing
up or not
usually applies to the situation she's
in now no don't get me wrong you know
what i'm saying pimps talk bad about
renegades and yeah every [ __ ] needs
some pepe man you know blah blah blah
you know it's easy to say that right but
i know some women men that are
professional escorts they don't do
relationships
they don't partner up with nobody they
don't have a man to report to her to go
home too
that's [ __ ] on them day and night you
get them saying they are independent
but they're successfully independent too
you feel me they're not on dope they're
not letting drugs compel them
they maintain their own rent so it's
like what do a pimp what does a pimp
have to offer them that they can't
provide for their self now what a woman
when i when when women that are
successful like that on an independent
base have asked me
what the [ __ ] do i need to give you the
money for and then they lay out the
credentials of how they got it going off
for themselves
believe it or not i actually stand down
i say hey more power to you it's all
good right
but when it's a woman talking about huh
if i sell my ass and just suck
somebody's dick the [ __ ] i look like
give me what i'ma give you the money for
man i pull a bankroll out of my pocket
and say i thought hundred dollar bill on
the ground say if you give me change for
20 you can pick up that hundred and keep
it
they always got excuse oh my money's in
the bank my money's on the card
uh i don't walk around all my money on
me they don't have it you get what i'm
saying so
and that's just usually the women is
what i call man haters you get what i'm
saying they're not gonna fall up under a
man
to where they got to partner up with
somebody so that's just the bug up they
asked man that was you know that's
another form of being a [ __ ] you just got
to let them be man because there's
plenty out there
you know what i'm saying and we all meet
each other those who meant to be for one
another as far as pimps and hoes and
who's compatible
they all eventually meet one another man
so we focus on the ones that's about it
not the ones who want to remain without
it you feel me i've also heard from a
lot of the guys that uh a lot of a lot
of the girls they'll work with
are terribly terribly bad with money
yeah well you know hey man i'm not a
doctor they can't handle yeah i know you
said i'm not a doctor i'm not a
psychologist i don't have a phd in
psychology or diagnosing things but one
thing i know from common knowledge is
self-education reading books when i was
in prison and stuff like that
and just from you know the experiences
right
a lot of profits but not all but there
are a lot who are bipolar one of the
things
bipolar is man they'll get a lump sum of
something and then i'll think of the
terms of a manager and i'm thinking that
like okay i gotta keep this and make it
last i gotta invest into something i
gotta flip it they think okay i got five
thousand dollars
i'm gonna go buy a whole bunch of [ __ ]
i'm feeling my friends i function what
i'm gonna make them happy and hand it
out and share with them if they're doing
drugs i'm for the go and you know
smoking out my partners and smoking them
and getting high with them and [ __ ] like
that
you know and then it's all gone to where
if they had a pimp and a [ __ ]
with the right kind of mind
you know the money wouldn't got [ __ ]
up they would still be able to be living
off that money as they're going along
in their relationship with the pimp you
feel me so you know a lot of it has to
do with bipolar a lot of it just has to
do with
certain women that don't have okay okay
men
especially pimps have the framework i'm
a king i will not go broke
i'm not gonna be a bum ass [ __ ] asking
nobody for a cigarette panhandling
asking my partner for a joke say p i
need a jig man you know pimp down
it's not cute it's not attractive you
get what i'm saying so by
us having that king-like ego that we're
supposed to have because we work hard to
maintain the things that make us a king
you know a [ __ ] ain't trying to
put yourself in a situation where the
bankroll is going backwards
you feel me so when a woman puts the
money in our hands it's not going to get
mishandled it's not going to get
mismanaged
and that's what she's going to give us
credit for inevitably you feel me
so i've seen you with different types of
girls tell me about the difference
between a white girl black girl mexican
girl
hey man there's an old saying right that
a a a black hole make you pimp with a
white hole let you pimp right but that's
just talking slicker [ __ ] like that
really it's like silky slim said
in this song i don't give a [ __ ] what
your racist we just give a [ __ ] with
your paces
you know it's more along them lines
right now when i was here before for an
interview i noticed i caused a uproar
on the feedback the comments i got from
the views on uh youtube or whatever
right about when i told you that i
prefer white women or hispanic women
over black women that caused
kind of an uproar right so i want to
take this moment to clarify something
because i got some i got some nasty
results man people said that's hitler
himself he's more racist than hitler
you know he's he's against his own
people and it's not like that man for
one
what what i may be attracted to
personally that's the same thing as any
basic
uh interracial relationship okay because
the whole world if they're available to
make a comment on something will comment
on oh that mexican woman is supposed to
be that asian guy or oh
that white woman ain't supposed to be
with that hindu over there i mean
but when it comes to human beings man
there should be no color lines as far as
love company companionship we're human
beings man if two different
ethnicities breeding was inappropriate
it wouldn't be able to make life i
myself am a product of the interracial
relationship what i mixed with
is not even relevant for me to comment
on this thing but as light as my skin is
i am mixed but hands down one of my
parents is black black than a
[ __ ] black it in the ace of
spades
i identify as black i've been on the
front line in prison
having riots race riots against other
races being called the n word
while me and the people other blacks is
outnumbered okay
fighting our asses off being called the
inward i've been on the front line of
what so make no mistake about it i am
black
and i am proud regardless of how light
or dark regardless of my complexion this
ain't
this ain't nothing real light skinny
nothing red goes back to the days of
prince all the way up to drake it ain't
steph curry it ain't nothing new right
so by no means am i racist against my
own people but when it comes to my
business
i deal with what works best for me you
know so i became accustomed to what
works best for me black women did not
work
best for me how will i who gives a [ __ ]
it is i love my sisters like i love my
brothers like i love myself
okay like i said one of my parents is
black meaning that
i have black grandparents i'm hood grew
up in the hood with blacks i function as
a black you know i'm not racist against
my own people and i would never want a
black woman
to say oh he think that you know uh uh
black women they get up because
if i say i pimp white women they're like
okay us black women ain't good enough
for you to work with if i say i work
with black women it's gonna be quick so
i'll be able to say he wants to do that
to his own race that are building up he
wants to break it down and have us
turn our sisters into prostitutes or
work our citizens process so i mean
there's no such thing like i said
earlier there's no such thing as
right or wrong everybody's gonna have an
opinion about something you mark your
photographer and the interviewer
there's people that might express
opposition to your job just because it's
not what they do
there's police officers dude are they
necessary in this environment
to an extent yeah if i see my mother
getting raped i would hope a police car
rolled by and intervene that [ __ ] do i
give a [ __ ] about the police
of course not i'm a criminal i've been
to prison you know i thug it i'm not
saying i'm an active criminal it's not a
self-emission but what i'm saying is
i'm more familiar with the criminal
culture than not so am i
in acceptance of the police and all they
do of course not but are they necessary
yes so i mean the same way pimp's
necessary same same reason why
you know white girls black girls
hispanic girls women of any ethnicity
end up with a pimp you know what i'm
saying the street level or whatnot you
know the black man's game to it
so you know it's not about a racist
thing it's what works for me
so the way the cars fell and so forth
you know white and hispanic and
non-black women are the ones who worked
who worked out for me in that business
making it what it was
and making me become the pimp that you
know i have lived as
you know so that's all that is right
there man my sister they can calm down
on that man you know two black too
strong
tell me about law enforcement law
enforcement man i think you mentioned
something like this before man
look let me tell you something i'm glad
you asked that mark you know and
somewhere around 2011 right
they came out with the human trafficking
thing okay and that enhanced
a basic pimple fence to where there's
other elements that was involved with it
it
gets exaggerated enhance the charges to
a whole bunch of crazy [ __ ] what pissed
me off is
the lawmakers who came up with this idea
when they when they ran the proposition
for i forgot what proposition it was
they shot the commercials man and had a
little girl swinging on a swing in a
playground then they say yeah these
women have taken off the streets and
turned into prostitutes and
made for human sex trafficking and it's
showing a little girl on the swing then
the swing disappearing
giving the public the image of pimp just
kidnapped a little kid
that's only if a kid is on a [ __ ]
swing they're obviously under 10 years
old
generally okay like a pimp is some kind
of big bad wolf predator and got this
exaggerated ass law
into existence but i personally that was
just too enhanced what i personally
don't like about is this here right
and i've read a whole lot of case laws
on pimp cases reading the whole trial
the results from what the charges work
and what i don't like about it is this
here right
it's denying a prostitute intimate
association with a man
that means every dick getting pumped in
her ass has to be that of a trick the
only time she gets to have sex with
somebody is in the commission over work
can a prostitute have a man can the
prisoner have somebody she come home to
and consider him
her superior the one that she does
something with that she don't do with
nobody else like bring him the money
because just like a a faithful wife in a
relationship
ain't gonna ain't supposed to just give
anybody some [ __ ] that's a sacred
you know activity between her and her
husband her and her boyfriend or her
spouse
well the sacred activity between a
prostitute and
her superior which would be her pimp her
folks or daddy or whatnot you know what
i'm saying
it's supposed to be the money she made
from that so she's throwing it in the
pot contributing to the household
you get what i'm saying now but that's
her intimate one right there that's
that's
that's her guy that's her dude he's that
guy you know what i'm saying so
how the [ __ ] is it law enforcement it's
supposed to tell a prostitute
you know with the end result being the
same whether they're telling her that
verbatim or not but how's the concept
still supposed to come down to
okay a prostitute ain't supposed to have
a man because
every every dollar that a man lives off
of or anybody lives off
of from a prostitute is a forbidden
dollar except with the exception of her
co-dependent children
you get what i'm saying i saw a case of
i've read case law where
[ __ ] in jail in prison for a
pimping charge because the guy was a
regular guy he was just a regular guy
live off social security check or
whatever
his wife of many years where they got
kids together by
happens to be a prostitute okay she goes
out and does her thing and
he's at home and he does a little thing
with her but he's not a pimp he don't
know other pimps he ain't out there no
tracks no
blades bringing girls out there he ain't
trying to recruit other girls he doesn't
call herself pursuing a career as a pimp
he just
her dude and whatever he stands in the
inside of a household that ain't
nobody's business but there and she
happens to be a prostitute but because
she goes out there and makes money that
way the police law enforcement get up in
a mix
and then it comes down to open yes i
live off some of the money she makes so
yes he lives yes some of the food in the
refrigerator was from my earnings as a
whole
because he's sitting down eating living
off that money that's a [ __ ] crime
you get what i'm saying so i mean you
know it's all it's just law enforcement
man you know what i'm saying trying to
trying to keep a hand in what they
personally don't like because you got
certain law enforcement squads man they
got narcotics squads they got
prostitution squads they got sex
offenders squads you know what i'm
saying every you know
police stations got their own particular
detail advice for certain jobs okay
yeah and a lot of ones that's on the
human trafficking and pimping the
prostitution vice squads man a lot of
them people that sign up for that
and this i know because i've been told
personally okay
they already don't like the concept of a
pimp being involved with a prostitute so
this is just their opportunity to carry
out a grudge because hey man don't
nobody like a pimp
except for another pyramid don't nobody
understand a pimp except for a hole in
another pimp
you feel me so this is a whole bunch of
pimp haters man just taking the law for
what it is how it's written how it
stipulated
and getting a little getting a little
revenge or a little resentment out you
know what i'm saying by
sticking sticking a hand in it and uh
doing it because i'll tell you what man
no girl that's ever been up under me is
a [ __ ] victim the crowd would like to
think of the girl's victim i've had
girls that had
previous recent previous ex-boyfriends
and [ __ ] like that that they just been
fresh out of relationships with like
that
and what word gets around they say hey
late man i heard man you're making her
do this or somebody's saying you could
really pimp it on the [ __ ]
i said does she look like she's being
gorilla pimped on she was looking like a
[ __ ] bum at first she's happy she's
sitting right there clarifying it like
no this was a [ __ ] upgrade
where has this guy been all my life and
i just wasted two or three years on such
and such that we're talking about this
ain't no forceful thing
but the guy the spouse from the previous
relationship once put it out there like
he can't accept that she's doing what
she's doing so he wants to look at her
like okay uh
she must have been forced to do this or
must have been coerced or tricked this
can't be
what it is with her you get what i'm
saying so it's more like something to
soothe a person's conscience you feel me
but uh you know hey man the women have
to go out to work
women that are grown enough to work the
streets to pay your pimp and understand
how to have that kind of job with the
rules and the guidelines and the morals
and the
cooperation and communication that comes
along with it knows god damn well man
how to find their way to the nearest
police station how to down 9-1-1
when they're fresh out of his sight and
get away from it ain't no victim
situation man that's just
that's just and you know when people
catch these pimp cases man
they describe the woman as the victim
law enforcement that is the victim on
the district attorney's side the victim
you get what i'm saying now don't get me
wrong there is a situation in a
situation that pimps don't really
respect
where a [ __ ] like i think
peanuty said it gorilla pimps
ain't really acknowledging they're not
really respected because they give
everybody a bad name
you feel me that they give people the
ammunition to think okay this is a
forceful situation she ain't doing that
she wants to
he she she's doing that because he's got
her out here doing it but you know what
no victim comes to mind when the girl's
doing it by herself
a person will be quicker to to pull a
girl to the side and say hey why do you
got a pimp why are you doing that for
him why is he making you do that they'll
be quicker to pull to the side and
express
opposition to her career as a prostitute
if she's with a pimp knowingly then it
will she's doing it by herself she's
doing it by herself all of a sudden they
want it if it's a man
he's trying to get his rocks off too if
it's another female oh i know this guy
she's trying to pick herself i know this
guy that'll pay you 300 girl you're
pretty you're just a type come on
now they trying to procure her for their
own benefits soon as the pimps involved
all of a sudden there's a whole bunch of
opposition and [ __ ] being expressed but
in most situations man the girl with the
pimp is looking better and doing better
and living better than one without the
pimp man so
i say all that to say man it's it's
highly exaggerated with the concept of
this imaginary concept
of who's a [ __ ] victim and not that's
uh that's just ensues the conscience man
and also it's to not make pimps appear
to be glorified because the media
you know with movies rap music you know
stuff like that man you know the word
pimp
became glorified something that appears
to be honorable in society something
that's leaning toward when it's
expressed
it it gets accepted and honored and
looked looked up upon
right so they came with the human
trafficking to try to put pimps
and you know sexual predators all the
same category
and that's a misconception man so i hope
something this video right here man
somebody that's clear minded enough to
understand what i'm saying
knows the difference i'm not saying
there's not situations like that but
it's not one i've ever been involved not
one of my partners and i [ __ ] with
other pimps that i've seen their
interviews on because we all appear to
be along the same lines
to a degree to a high degree okay so you
know
i just had to clear that up real quick
that's a very good explanation of
of aspects of this that are very
misunderstood i think well somebody's
got to say it man because they don't man
people are going to run around with this
misconception that uh
a pimp is a sucker a pimp is a predator
you know and stuff like that man but you
know that's just
outside of looking in at the surface
because they don't get much behind the
scenes footage unless
of course you know mark the thing you
guys said where people can hear it from
another aspect
the outside you know the inside coming
out and there's many different levels of
this game that they're very
oh it varies man you know like like i
said earlier man you know
with the nba and and the dmv rules you
know it's one general set of rules
okay but everybody does it their own way
which works for them
regardless of the methods you know the
internet you know what i'm saying uh the
streets
uh bars what the [ __ ] ever okay uh what
ethnicity of the girls they work with i
work with them
you know everybody does it different
yeah excellent like
thank you so much but hey man for the
record man just just for the record i'd
like to say i like to sign up for this
note man late the great the golden state
heavyweight man a young host dream a
white hose king and a square's nightmare
man and i'm out
thank you late
you